Anger boils over into violent
protests at the world's
largest iPhone factory
worker stream out of Foxconn's
factory dorms in Central China.
Ho, ho.
Protesting unfair treatment,
dirty living
conditions and chaotic COVID
rules at the Apple supplier.
Videos obtained by CNN
show a group of police
in white hazmat suits
beating workers
with batons and metal rods.
The police are hitting people.
A worker shouts in the video.
A Foxconn
employee at the protest told CNN
the scene turned into a river of blood.
Police hit the workers
ruthlessly shortly,
which occurred earlier.
Squadrons of riot police had roll death.
They're going to start beating us.
Protesters yelled in fear,
facing off
rows of law enforcement with riot gear.
The protest escalated into the evening.
Workers tearing down covered barriers
using metal beams against police
boxes of
them, hurling
metal parts towards law enforcement,
even using a COVID barrier
as a shield against rows of authorities.
They worked together
to push over a police car,
cheering and chanting.
Since October,
the Foxconn plant
has been sealed off
from the outside world
after a COVID outbreak
that forced employees to live
and work on site
In what videos obtained by
CNN show
are filthy conditions,
garbage piling up in the hallway.
The factory plunged into chaos.
Videos
showed workers
scrambling, fighting
to get enough food and supplies.
Then came the exodus.
Masses of workers
walked miles
along highways
to escape the plant Analysts
estimate this factory produces
more than half of Apple's iPhones.
Apple already warned customers
they'll need to wait even longer
to get their new products
because of China's COVID lockdowns.
So to attract workers,
Foxconn promised higher pay and bonuses.
New workers signed up.
But when they got to the factory,
the pay package was worse
than what Foxconn advertised.
Tamika NGO Play piano.
A Foxconn employee, said
workers felt cheated,
leading to thousands
of people protesting.
Foxconn later
blamed the payment
discrepancy on a, quote, technical error
and sent text messages to workers
offering
to pay them $1,400 to quit and go.
Soon after video
showed
long lines of workers
boarding busses to leave the factory.
Their departure
possibly putting an end to another
violent and dramatic scene,
but increasing the pressure on Apple.
It's just the latest victim of China's
zero COVID policy.
Since the city,
the place where that factory is located,
they've just announced
they're going to be lifting the lockdown.
But that's not going to immediately
reverse the damage for Apple
and the damage is huge.
Analysts are estimating
it was costing
Apple roughly
$1,000,000,000 a week in lost
iPhone sales.
Erin.
And after Selena's report,
I want to bring you more now
of our conversation earlier
with how
he is from the eastern part of China.
He is now studying in England.
And this is an interview
you'll see only here.
I began by asking him about his family
who are still in China.
I asked whether he's worried about them.
Here's his response.
Yeah, absolutely.
Worried about them
because
I think I still need to do something
because some
some people in China,
they are protesting against
the government.
So they are taking a much more
much bigger risk of them.
So
even if I
I am worried that I have to do this.
When you say you have to do this,
what made you decide to actually protest
my peace and I have to have
my duty to,
like do something to call
for their human rights and a normal life
for the people in China.
Have you spoken to your friends
who are in China and are they scared?
They are mostly worried
about what will happen
after these protests
and after the lockdown
because the Chinese government
is imposing
restrictions even harder on this,
on the control of the speech of assembly
and on demonstration.
Some people were arrested
during the protests and
the much more was is they are
randomly checking the polls,
posing the citizens
to hand handling their phones.
They do not
respect the human rights of privacy
and liberty.
You experience the lockdown in Shanghai
at university.
I know before
you moved to England for school
and I know they told you
how that the lockdown
there would be six to seven days,
but it ended up being three months.
And some of the details
of what you experienced are really hard
and frankly incredible. To imagine.
Can you tell us about things
like using the bathroom
and about the food
and in the lockdown, the Shanghai,
the all access to Shanghai is control
or are controlled by the government,
which means you
any any one that wants to transfer
some resources like the food,
like the vegetables, meat,
they have to get the
official permit permission
from the government
that the food we are receiving,
we received like is
most us
many times we eat some very, very bad
and some from my meters like stomachache
or from there some box
and the food's in the air
and there are some
residents receiving
the the bad
vegetables, the back meats
and even some received none of them
they are starving at home
and even someone like they died
because of the starving so it's very bad.
And also like
in the restrictions and the lockdown,
we we talked all night at the beginning.
We played cop games 15 days.
But after those days we are like
we don't want to.
So anything
we just lie down
in the bath and staring at the ceiling
wasting our time
because our
our spirit is actually exhausted.
How the world
is watching these protests now
and wondering how big
this will get
and whether this is about more
than just zero COVID,
whether it's about freedom
in a bigger sense.
What do you think of Xi
Jinping's leadership?
I think it's a continuous
dictatorship of the country
because there are many people are not
comfortable and
agree with him,
but no one can just maybe say
they spoke out.
It's a big
that they don't like him
because if you do, you might be monitored
and maybe you will be arrested.
Maybe you are in custody.
It's like a control of your liberty.